present the award for outstanding
achievement in directing a beautiful
young lady who wanted oscar with a very
first movie she ever made Goldie Hawn
and the brilliant young man who rekt who
directed two of the biggest films the
last few years jaws and Close Encounters
of the Third Kind Steven Spielberg
the nominees for outstanding achievement
in directing are Bob Fosse all that jazz
Francis Coppola for Apocalypse Now
teacher Yates for breaking away
Robert Benton for Kramer vs Kramer
and edweb Molinaro for LoCascio fold the
long way around the winner is Robert
Benton for kangaroo
thank you all very much
I would like to thank every Corman wrote
a lovely book I would like to thank
Stanley Jaffe the producer Dustin
Hoffman Meryl Streep Jane Alexander
Justin Henry
Jobeth Williams I would I think like to
thank Jerry Greenberg the editor mr.
almond Rossa cinematographer I would
like to thank all the people at Columbia
past and present I would like to thank
Sam cone Orlean Donovan my wife Sally
and my son Joan thank you
ladies and gentlemen Charlton Heston
the nominees for best picture of the
year are all that jazz
at Columbia 20th Century Fox production
20th Century Fox Robert Alan Arthur
producer Apocalypse Now and Omni
zoetrope production United Artists
Francis Coppola producer Fred ruse Gary
Fredrickson and Tom Sternberg
co-producers 20th Century Fox production
20th Century Fox
Peter Yates producer
Kramer vs Kramer Stanley Jaffe
productions Columbia Stanley R Jaffe
producer
and Norma Rae at 20th Century Fox
production 20th Century Fox Tamar asaf
and Alex Rose producers
and the winner is Kramer versus friend
oh boy I grew up in a home that's been
associated with this business for 51
years this has always been very
important to all of us as a
representation of excellence
I stand here very happy and very blessed
blessed because the person they may
recall man wrote a book called Kramer vs
Kramer lucky because Richard fish-off
came to work for me that week and found
the book less because Bob Benton was
free and he wrote and directed it and I
was lucky enough to be able to get along
with Bob and words he wrote Dustin and
Merrill Jane and Justin and it's a film
that's made with love and it's made
about love and it was cut by Jerry and
Nestor shot it and it would not have
been made had it not been for the
encouragement of Columbia Pictures Frank
price john beach and most especially two
dear friends of mine Dan Melnick and
Sherry Lansing it is about love and from
four people in my life I have learned
more about that than ever
I speak of ingerborg Sorenson and her
son Adam and I speak about my children
Bobby and Betsy thank you all very much
you